the PlayStation Plus lineup for July has
been revealed and the service is
celebrating its 10th anniversary to
celebrate we're getting a third free
game in the new month so if you're a
subscriber here's what's coming your way
the first game on the list is NBA 2k 20
last year's basketball game was the
first to include teams from the WNBA and
it also brought back the my career my GM
and my league modes my team is also back
letting you build your own dream team
using virtual trading cards
the second ps+ game is rise of the Tomb
Raider which is also the second entry in
the most recent trilogy this one sees
Lara Croft exploring Siberia as she
deals with the military force Trinity
expect plenty of puzzles and challenging
tombs and your bonus game for July is
the ps4 exclusive Erica this FMV game
lets you interact with scenes and make
choices that affect how they play out it
might look like a thriller movie but
there's more than one ending to this
story and those are your free
PlayStation Plus games for July they'll
be available from July 7th through
August 3rd keep an eye out for a free PS
Plus theme too although we don't have
any details on that just yet and stay
tuned as we report on the new PS Plus
lineup every month
[Music]
you